(upbeat rock music)
- The mission of Improbable
AI Lab is to build robots
which can perform the same physical tasks
that humans perform today.
The things that we want robots to be doing
so humans can focus on
what they are good at,
and what they want to do to
realize their full potential.
In simulation, our robots are
learning by trial and error.
They're essentially trying to figure out
what sequence of commands
should they give to their legs.
One fun task is for these
robots to play soccer,
and definitely there
has been a lot of work
in robots playing soccer,
but a lot of this work
has been with robots
which are not as agile or dynamic.
- Legs robots are really
interesting to work with
because they're a bit
challenging to control.
To dribble a soccer ball,
it's not sufficient for the robot to rely
on what it feels through its motors.
It also needs to know
where the soccer ball is,
and there's not enough
information about that
in just what the robot's feeling.
It needs vision.
It needs to be able to perceive
the ball from a distance
and run to it and also kick it
when it's sort of underneath the robot,
even if it's moving in a
way that's not expected.
For this, we actually
do leverage the cameras
in the robot's head and body
to detect and perceive the ball
and make decisions based
on that information.
Our robot's having a problem,
which is when it kicks the ball on grass,
the ball slows down and
it recaptures the ball
and it keeps dribbling.
But when it kicks the ball on pavement,
the ball just keeps you rolling forever,
because it doesn't slow down.
So we implemented a drag model
to model how the robot
slows down on grass,
but we need to modify it so
that the robot is capable
of catching up when the ball's
rolling fast on pavement.
I think it's fun to watch a
human interact with the robot,
and the soccer ball is a
really good medium for that.
- So what you're going to
see in many of these videos
is robots dancing, going under things,
going over obstacles, running
on ice, many different things.
We don't have to go to each task
and have a human do our design strategies
which are specific to that task.
All of these strategies are a result
of the same way of training the robot.
We train in simulation by trial and error,
and then deploy them in the real world.
- We're excited to continue our research
on legged robotics to
unlock their potential
to accomplish dynamic
tasks in their environment
and assist humans.